Dia 304 de la volta al món a peu, dilluns 28 de setembre.
Ara fa cinc minuts, mentre estava assegut allà, avorridíssim,
m'arriba un mail, l'obro i diu
Pisa de Paquistan aprovada.
A més, 60 dies.
Jo havia demanat 90, però es veu que no et donen 90
si no tens una carta de recomanació d'una agència.
Però m'han donat 60, dos mesos.
Crec que hauria de ser suficient, ho he de revisar bé.
Però bueno, estic molt content, molt content.
Avui, dia 28, són les 8 i 20 de la tarda.
Per tant, avui és el moment perfecte
perquè m'adonessin, si m'arriben a dur demà, malament.
Per què? Demà al matí, i ara ja no puc,
demà al matí vaig fins a Tashkorgan amb autobús.
I he d'anar per la tarda a comprar els tíquets pel bus
que va fins a Paquistan.
Recordeu que només puc treure la frontera
amb un bus que surt des de Tashkorgan.
I això serà el dia 30 de setembre, d'aquí dos dies.
I el dia 1 la frontera ja està tancada
perquè de l'1 al 7 d'octubre hi ha vacances xineses.
I la frontera està tancada per qualsevol
de l'1 al 4, amb dos inclosos.
Per tant, si m'arriba a arribar de mal visat,
doncs no podria creuar la frontera ja fins al dia 5.
Estaria aquí atrapat.
Bueno, igualment serà una aventura creuar aquesta frontera
perquè, bueno, m'han dit que és una locura,
especialment en dates assenyalades com aquestes
que el calendari xinès comença a tancar fronteres.
Tothom vol anar ràpid a creuar la frontera
i serà una locura, ja m'han dit com serà.
Però, bueno, és igual, és igual.
Estic content, he rebut el visat, visca.
I, bueno, ara, última nit a Kashgar, celebraré.
Vaig a sopar amb un noi xinès que he conegut aquí.
També farem unes cerveses després.
I demà, cap a Kashgar, i demà passat torna l'aventura.
En principi ja torno a caminar.
No m'ho esperava, això.
Dimarts 29 de setembre, 9 i mitja del matí.
Quina son.
Fa cinc dies que a la meva habitació del hostel
dorm un tio que ronca tota la nit.
Però ja està, s'ha acabat.
Aquesta és la furgoneta que m'ha de portar fins a Pescurgant.
Primera part del viatge, unes 5-6 hores.
120 yuan, que vindrien a ser uns 15-16 euros.
A passar-ho el més ràpid possible.
A veure si veiem neu.
Si veiem neu, vol dir que també trobarem neu a l'altre pas,
al pas de frontera amb Pakistan.
3 i mitja, 5 hores més tard, ja he arribat a Treshkurgant.
Tres setmanes.
I un dia feia que me'n vaig anar d'aquí.
Molt bé.
Doncs a partir d'ara hi ha informacions contradictòries
sobre el que he de fer per comprar els bitllets
per l'autobús de demà.
Us recordo que per anar fins a Pakistan
l'única manera és agafant un autobús
des d'aquí fins a Pakistan.
Alguns diuen que s'ha d'anar el dia anterior,
és a dir, avui,
i l'oficina obre de 4 de la tarda a 6.
És a dir, d'aquí mitja hora.
Però després altra gent m'ha dit
que no, que va anar de 4 a 6 el dia anterior
i estava tancat i li van dir
que tornés el dia següent, a les 9 del matí.
Jo crec que ho intentaré.
A més, tenint en compte que tinc l'hotel
i l'he agafat especialment
a prop de l'estació d'autobusos,
crec que el primer que faré serà anar a l'hotel,
deixar la motxilla
i anar a mirar, a veure què hi ha
a la zona del bus.
També tinc bastanta gana,
però crec que no n'ha de menjar ara mateix.
Porto una estona aquí
al lobby de l'hotel
i no apareix ningú.
Així que, bé, com que està aquí al costat, en teoria,
la parada de bus, vaig a veure què hi ha.
Queden 5 minuts per les 4.
Una de les persones que diu
que ho va aconseguir
va haver d'esperar fins a les 6 menys quart,
llavors van obrir 15 minuts
i van poder comprar el tiquet.
Haver d'esperar dues hores
seria un palazo,
però, bé, potser és el que més m'agrada.
És el que hi ha, eh?
Bueno, pel que sembla, el bus de Pakistan,
o els busos, perquè n'hi ha molts,
deuen haver arribat, perquè hi ha moltíssima gent
que està sortint de...
que està caminant en direcció oposada a mi.
Ara estic gravant així una mica les trànsits
perquè hi ha un poli que m'ha parat i m'ha dit
ei, espera aquí, espera aquí.
Hi ha un altre grup de pakistanesos
que també vol comprar el bitllet per demà,
llavors suposo que hem d'esperar...
bueno, m'han dit que hem d'esperar mitja hora
per...
bueno, suposo que que la gent escampi la boida,
llavors nosaltres podem comprar el tiquet per demà.
Avui i demà
els dies consistiran en esperar molt.
Aprofito aquesta mitja hora, ara sí,
per fer xequin a l'hotel, per fi.
Habitació només per mi.
El tio em demanava que apagués.
Que apagués l'habitació, ja l'havia apagat online, saps?
Bueno, una mica...
una mica descontrol.
Doncs molt bé, tu, l'habitació.
Andoi Europeu.
L'altra vegada que estava aquí t'escorcant,
us en recordeu, no?
Que vaig tenir problemes amb l'Andoi.
Està molt bé, l'habitació.
Podré descansar bé aquesta nit.
Vinga, a veure si...
Oh, i un lau, com Déu mana.
A veure si puc menjar alguna cosa abans de...
d'esperar a la cua.
Vale, m'havien dit mitja hora.
Han passat 15 minuts
i ja no hi ha ningú aquí.
En cas d'un dena.
Bueno, vaig cap allà.
A veure, no sé.
Bueno, acabo d'arribar.
Estan obrint portes.
M'hauré col·locat millor, però...
Bueno.
Bueno, doncs a veure.
A veure quant trigo a comprar el tiquet.
La situació és que sóc al...
Bueno, vintè de la cua,
però he vist gent darrere meu
que li ha donat diners al de davant
perquè li compri el bitllet ahir.
I, doncs, ens han deixat entrar...
a l'estació aquesta, però...
no hi ha de moment ningú atenent.
Bueno, tu, mira.
He pogut menjar una mica de crispetes dolces
que no m'agraden, però...
m'heu perdut la panxa, com a mínim.
Avui no havia menjat res, encara.
Gairebé una hora d'espera,
però he pogut.
He comprat el tiquet.
Això vol dir que demà tinc garantida
la sortida a Pakistan.
Home, jo diria que sí, no?
El 99%.
Que bé, 30 euros.
He pogut pagar amb Alipay.
I, bueno, la gent es colava,
saps? Ja m'havien advertit d'això.
I demà encara serà pitjor.
La gent colada, en principi, els estrangers tenim una cua especial
per demà, per saltar-nos
tots els pakistanesos.
Una mica discriminatori, però, bueno.
Ho aprofitarem, saps? No em queixaré.
Val, són les cinc i pico.
Descanso una estona a l'hotel
i després fem l'últim àpat
a la Xina.
Dinar sopar.
Últim àpat de restaurant a la Xina.
Què hauríem de menjar? Porc, no?
Porc perquè ara a Pakistan no en menjaré.
Però crec que aquesta zona
tajica, zona de...
restaurants tajics, llavors,
el ser musulmà, dubto molt que trobem el porc.
Potser uns noodles.
Noodles... crec que al Pakistan
són més d'arròs.
Ei, mira, una vaca.
A veure què hi ha.
No sé si us ho havia explicat, però aquí a la Xina,
com a mínim aquesta és una xing-chang,
sempre posen
te
per menjar, no? Gratuit.
I he vist a molts xinesos,
agafen, es posen el te
a la tassa,
ho miren,
fan com miren o no sé què fan,
mesquen una mica i ho llencen.
Ho llencen a les converies.
Un cop que vaig preguntar m'han dit
que era perquè és per si hi havia aigua,
doncs llençar l'aigua.
Perquè potser, no ho sé, no ho sé.
Jo no ho faré, perquè he vist que
el llencen a les
papeles aquestes que hi ha aquí.
Són una mica rars.
Crec que a Pakistan també menjarem
bastant de chai, te.
A l'hora de demanar
a la Xina no et pots equivocar, no pots tenir
dubtes. Mira,
he preguntat si els fideus que posa,
fideus amb porc, segons el traductor,
he preguntat si portaven porc i m'han dit que no.
Llavors he dit, bé, doncs portem uns
dumplings, que també són una cosa bastant xinesa,
i aquesta espècie de bolets
amb cosa, bueno, amb verdures
i una bruixeta.
Ja he considerat que era bastant menjar.
I com que no m'havien portat tot,
em porten els fideus, que era
en badella, crec. I jo, no, però no ho he
demanat. I bueno, va, és igual.
És igual. No m'ho he acabat tot,
com veieu aquí. Està a mitja cavar,
impossible.
Però bueno, va, t'ho he menjat bé.
Dimec...
Dimecres 30 de
setembre, són les 8 i mitja,
i avui és un dia
molt important, no només a la volta
a Bonapau, sinó a la meva vida, que és que
creuaré la frontera més alta del món.
Cosa que poca gent pot dir.
I hauria de ser un dia,
doncs, guai, no?
Ilusionant, però
crec que serà un dia
pesat, feixuc,
llarg
i un rotllo.
Un rotllo per a totes les cues
que hauré de fer. I perquè estic una mica
encostipat, tu. Una mica, no sé,
algú tinc? Mira'm el cos.
Algú tinc, no és greu, però
m'estan mocant.
Tinc mocadors,
no dormim bé,
desastre, eh? Avui és el dia per
dormir bé, eh? En fi,
farem el que podrem.
Queda d'això, a les 9 obren,
vaig tirant cap allà
i, bueno, doncs, anem a fer el resum
de Xina, no? Encara que no he caminat gaire per aquí, doncs,
a veure, què són les 3 coses que
m'han agradat més. El número 3
diré el Mustangata.
Engellen les muntanyes, no? Molt guapes,
aquí el Pamir, ja nevades, ja estic veient des d'aquí.
Però, en concret, aquesta, ostres,
un 100.500, ha sigut una
cosa molt guai de veure.
En el número 2, el menjar,
molt bo, variat, econòmic,
n'he parlat molt d'això, ja.
I en el número 1,
el millor de la Xina, doncs,
tornar al primer món.
Tot el que és comoditats, sistema
d'adrenatge, carrers ben
pavimentats,
poder pagar targeta,
comprar una mica,
tenir disponibilitat de comprar coses, no?, en general.
Molt bé, molt bé.
Si tota la volta per una peu fos així,
doncs, home, diria no, no? Però,
però això ha estat guai. Molt bé.
Bueno, jo no sé si podré
gravar. Ahir m'han dit que,
ahir vaig gravar una mica,
però m'han dit que alguns que vam veure
filmant, els havien fet borrar el vídeo.
Per tant, el que faré serà
intentar gravar
d'estrangis, i si no
puc gravar, doncs, no puc gravar.
Ah, quina son.
Ahir m'han dit que hauré de córrer
fins a la part d'etat de l'entrada,
que és quan hi ha, on hi ha la cua
dels turistes.
La persona que em va dir això era turista
i no havia comprat l'etiquet.
Jo ja el vaig comprar ahir. Llavors, potser
he vingut d'hora i, a més, corro
per res.
Podria ser tranquil·lament.
El procés és molt,
molt, molt, no, no, ningú t'explica
res, ningú sap res.
Bueno, crec que no calia que
corrés, perquè, sí,
de la cua dels turistes he sigut el primer. Bueno, ha estat bé,
ficar-me davant de la porta,
independentment de ser corregut o no.
Sí, sí, ara mateix comença a formar una fila
a la cua de turistes. Si no em pagués tan esos,
o sigui, que és raro que siguin turistes,
doncs, bueno, és igual. Hi ha ara mateix
20 persones darrere meu
i això és bo, perquè m'han dit
que més o menys cada
persona que tinc davant potser
fa que trot tinguin 15 minuts més.
Per tant, sóc el primer.
Visca. Doncs ja està.
Bueno, no està, però...
Sí, sí, està el primer de la cua. Llavors,
ha començat a venir gent, gent, després ha vingut un poli,
fiqueu-vos en fila, tal.
Hi havia gent que ha entrat a colar. Jo hi ha hagut
un que l'he empès.
L'he fet així, tio, on vas?
S'ha aconseguit colar igualment. Després,
però bueno, jo era el primer, és igual.
Llavors, com que jo ja tenia el tíquet, no he hagut
d'anar a la fila de comprar el tíquet, he hagut d'anar
simplement a la fila
d'aquí, que em van
lideixen el tíquet, i pujar al bus. I ja està,
i sóc el primer al bus.
Perfecte, tu.
Moltíssimes gràcies a tots els que m'han ajudat,
els grups de WhatsApp i altres viatgers
que m'havien trobat, el que sigui, que m'havien
donat consells de com fer això ràpid.
Ara és qüestió d'esperar
un munt d'estona, igual, però és molt millor
esperar qui ha sabut
que a cada peu.
Molt millor. Val. Què passa
ara? Això no s'ha acabat. Uf, encara no s'ha acabat.
D'aquí una estona llarga
anirem a immigració
xinesa, on
també tindré una fila especial
per...
com a estranger, i per res.
Sortida de Xina, no sé com serà,
però suposo que hem revisat l'equipatge,
m'estampava el passaport.
Un altre cop al bus, i ja
tot el camí, tota la carretera, que llavors
ja us tornaré a parlar, fins a Pakistan.
Per cert, no sóc l'únic malalt
a la qual hi havia un munt de gent tossint.
També pel fred, saps?
Fa fred, fa fred.
Però alguna passa deu haver-hi.
Com va la immigració?
Bé, doncs ja hem passat la...
Vaja, flemes que tinc.
Bé, ja hem passat la immigració xinesa.
No ha sigut un escàner de...
i m'han mirat tot el que porto a la motxilla,
com van fer a l'entrar, no?
No ha sigut el primer aquesta vegada perquè hi ha un autobús
que són japonesos
i han entrat abans
perquè és un autobús que és només per ells.
Van a fer alguna cosa d'alpinisme
perquè porten a Japó el Pine Club.
Bé, no ha sigut lent tampoc.
Però he de dir que els xinesos,
jo em faran unes preguntes
quan estàs allò donant el passaport.
O per on vas entrar a la Xina?
Tio, però si ho poses allà, tio.
Però bé, ja està, ja està.
Ara res, parar el bus
i ja cap a Pakistan.
Let's go!
Bé, després de gairebé dues hores esperant,
ja estem en moviment.
Són les 12 i mitja,
o 12 i pico.
En total, des de les 9,
doncs 3 hores i pico.
Bueno, com mínim he pogut estar assegut.
Ara són 124 quilòmetres
fins a la frontera
amb Pakistan
i atenció, 1.600 metres de desnivell positiu.
Sort que crec
que estic bastant aclimatat
de la zona del Pamir perquè...
Això és molt desnivell, eh?
Bé,
intentaré gravar una mica el paisatge.
Suposo que hi ha algun checkpoint, no sé què.
I també vindrà, un cop creuat Pakistan,
el timo del Parc Nacional.
O sigui, just després de la frontera
hi ha una zona que és un parc nacional.
A Pakistan, a muntanyes, natura i tal.
Ok.
I tu, per arribar fins a Sost,
aquest bus haurà de travessar el parc nacional
però per una carretera.
No baixarem i gaudirem del parc nacional.
No farem cap excursió,
simplement passarem per la carretera.
Bueno, doncs és un timo.
Anegut i molt habitual
que quan passes per allà
et fan pagar l'entrada al parc nacional.
Encara que...
És un timo que...
I el pagarem dòlars perquè és el que tinc
i no tinc moneda paquistanesa.
No sé quant és, eh?
De quantitat, no sé si seran 30 euros.
Una barbaritat.
És un timo dels gordos.
I un dia, per res, el carrer de cada persona
que del pèl és a la flor de la ment.
A la blau i a la
peça,
el camí no es repetirà...
La vivència en què està capaç de continuar
és el que esteu veient ara.
No hi ha cap sinistre,
per l'entrlà,
per el que ens falta,
per la fora,
per la mesura,
per la lluita,
per la sort,
per laanki,
per la lluita,
per la lluita i per la lluita.
I per tu, del parc nacional.
No estic aquí.
Estic aquí.
Fins demà!
El paisatge...
Molt emocionant, molt emocionant.
Encara que sigui en bus, molt emocionant.
Que bé tu, que bé.
Cap mal d'altura, cap mareig, cap res.
Buah, eh...
Primers quilòmetres per Pakistan?
Primers quilòmetres per la carretera del Karakor,
un famosíssima.
Primeres impressions, es condueix per l'esquerra.
No ho sabia, tu.
No ho sabia. Crec que és el primer país
de la volta amb una peu que condueixen per l'esquerra.
Diria que sí.
Bueno, la carretera...
està pavimentada.
És probable perquè passin dos camions
a dures penes.
I ara
hem fet la pujada progressiva des de la Xina,
però la baixada ara és brutal.
Des d'aquí...
Des d'aquí ja, fins a Sost,
baixem 2.000 metres.
Dels 4.700 als 2.800.
Sí, sí, sí.
Que bé, tu. Que bé.
No hi ha cobertura, vull dir.
La història...
En la pel·lícula el canvia completament.
Bueno, doncs aquesta ha sigut l'oficina
on he hagut de pagar 30 dòlars, han sigut.
He pagat en dòlars
i m'han donat el canvi en dòlars.
Però res, 30 dòlars
per veure les vistes.
M'estic pixant, crec que no puc menjar res aquí.
Doncs ja hem arribat a Sost.
Ara el que toca és
entrar a Paquistan.
No hauria d'haver-hi cap problema, tinc el visat.
Tot bé, i ja seré lliure.
Per fi.
Doncs ja està.
Ja ho tenim. He de dir que
la infraestructura paquistanesa és més modesta
que la xinesa, però hi havia
molt més ordre. Hi havia un poli a dintre
controlant que ningú es colés.
I tot estava en una fila
molt ben posada, tu. Molt bé.
Quina vall més espectacular, eh?
Té el punt Pamir,
aquest saccarral, però té aquesta
muntanya d'aquí davant, en aquesta
forma de pic.
I després aquests arbres així.
Ara que ja comencen
a agrugir-se.
Són les dos i mitja. He retrocedit en el temps.
Sí.
És que, clar, l'hora xinesa
de Pequín no tenia cap sentit.
I ara torno a estar
a l'hora que tenia Tajikistan. És a dir,
tres hores de diferència amb Catalunya
envers els sis hores de diferència
que tenia abans.
Estic petat.
Mira, ja està el meu hotel. Sí, avui,
com no sabia quan trigaria això,
m'he agafat un hotel.
Bueno, clar, jo qui sabia, saps?
Però sí, avui podria caminar.
Avui podria caminar perquè són les
dues i pico, com ja et dic.
Encara tinc hores de sol,
però no, no. Vaig a l'hotel.
Sí, sí, sí. Vaig a l'hotel
perquè estic rebentat.
Doncs, per acabar el dia,
encara que són les tres,
un arròs fregit amb pollastre,
que és bastant xinès,
però vindria a ser una mica
l'arròs tres delícies, no? Que no he menjat a la Xina.
I després anem a canviar diners, també, al mercat.
Doncs ja bastanta vidilla,
qui sost.
Em trobo fatal.
Ui, ui, ui, ja ho veuràs.
Bueno.
Bueno, doncs això.
Bueno, intentaré canviar 170 dòlars
i
també tinc 100 yuans
i també tinc encara moneda de Tajikistan.
No era que me l'acceptin, però bueno, potser sí.
I després també comprar alguna coseta
allà de postres
i per sopar i cap a l'hotel
a morir.
Doncs aquest és el Banc Nacional
de Pakistan. M'he espantat
un munt perquè
quan diu, sí, sí, aquesta quantitat, aquesta quantitat,
comença a treure un feix de bitllets,
tres tacos, però gegants. I dic,
ua, ja veuràs que aquí serà
com Tajikistan
que la moneda està tan avaluada i no.
No, no, o potser sí que ho està, però en qualsevol cas
han imprimit bitllets nous
i hi ha bitllet de 5.000.
Llavors, però això, tinc 55.000
no sé ni com es diu,
rupis.
Rupis, d'acord.
Molt bé, senyors. Doncs en realitat tinc més coses a explicar-vos
de coses d'aquests últims dies,
amb unes coses de logística o el que sigui,
però avui el vídeo està quedat molt llarg.
Ho deixem per demà.
Si és que demà hi ha vídeo.
Perquè ara mateix no tinc internet.
Jo m'he piat...
A veure, us ho explico, que això és important.
Per pillar una sim
paquistanesa m'he d'anar a un poble
que està a 90 km d'aquí.
Això, si et tirés molt la saco,
podria arribar en dos dies,
però no crec, seran tres dies.
Llavors, entre mig,
m'havia pillat una sim,
però arribo aquí
i no funciona. I dic, ostres,
podria ser que l'operadora que pia
la sim, que és una operadora no random,
però és una operadora així,
doncs no funcioni.
Perquè aquí, en aquesta vall,
només hi ha una operadora, i potser estic a una altra operadora.
Però és que el wifi de l'hotel
tampoc funciona.
El que vol dir que, jo què sé,
potser no funciona en tota sort
l'internet. Llavors, doncs bé,
no us amoïneu si no hi ha vídeo,
doncs mira, no tinc...
no tinc internet, coses que passen.
Vinga, bona tarda,
bona nit, fins demà.